democratic mayor of fort lauderdale
florida getting called out for rushing
to judgment
about a deadly crash at a pride parade
event this weekend
instead of just waiting for all the
facts to come in the mayor jumped to
this conclusion what we saw it was a
terrorist attack on the lgbt community
this is disgusting we will not stand for
this
this is not going to happen in my city
or any city
well the mayor was forced to backtrack
after police said it appeared the
tragedy
was an accident i regret the fact
that i said it was a terrorist attack
because we found out that it was not
but i don't regret my feelings i don't
regret
that i felt terrorized oh please
greg he when the mayor said that the
venomous twidiates immediately spread it
around and it quickly turned into
a homophobic attack that was caused by
ron desantis the governor of florida and
i'm not
i'm not joking so wait that's not true
oh there go my talking points uh
he the guy should have just stopped
before he said but
why what i mean look we've all been
suckered in by our own cognitive biases
uh
when you see a story online and you just
go and get you go
this what he was his cognitive biases
led to wishful thinking representing his
fact
the mayor did not know that attack was
an attack
but he wanted it to be an attack and
that was
all that that was all that mattered he
surrounds himself with news sources that
indulges bias
again all of us you know we can be so we
can say that this happens to us
but the problem in our current climate
right now is that
social media rewards uh those who assume
the worst intention
like imagine if everybody on twitter
imagined the best intentions right there
would be no twitter
it would be gone there would be no
trends but in order to
he assumed the very worst that there's
this massive like
i don't know underground homophobic
movement that's sending cars into
you know meanwhile the story that's not
being discussed
we mentioned in the a block was the
puerto rican parade in which you know a
puerto rican
couple was pulled out by a mob and shot
to death one is
that both was shot but one is dead
imagine if these situations were
reversed yep
why couldn't the mayor just wait well i
think he was looking for his 15 minutes
of fame yeah
and maybe it was his instinct but in
terms of the bias right he's like oh
gosh here we go he's going to be a
terrorist attack it's on my watch i'm
the mayor
instead of like basically he had had a
reckless disregard
for the public's trust and also you have
to ask if somebody who is an elected
official if their first thought is
innocent until proven guilty
if that's not your first thought then
you may be in the wrong line of work as
we've heard
the phrase we've heard this next couple
weeks exactly
and to greg's point that jessica part of
the problem is is these
lies or false narratives whatever you
want to call them they live on
forever i will look and this is a glenn
greenwald
article that he wrote the pulse
nightclub shooting happened about five
years ago
and that politicians and activists every
year
talk about that it was an anti-lgbtq
hatred it was a hate crime that is not
true
and you had u.s senators uh
kind of tammy duckworth senator
duckworth was the worst
but that's not what happened omar mateen
was motivated by rage over president
obama's bombing campaigns in syria iraq
and afghanistan and it's in the 9-1-1
call
there are court transcripts about it but
literally u.s senators every year
are tweeting about it was this hate
crime and he picked it at random and
didn't know that it was
a gay nightclub but again the lie lives
on and it
dishonors the victims frankly well i'm
not sure and i
many of the parents of the pulse
nightclub shooting victims don't feel
that way because
it was still a large amount it was 49
people that were killed and
they were members of the lgbtq plus
community yeah and that means
it doesn't i understand the difference
between motivation and results but the
result
was 49 people are dead and i believe a
majority i don't want to say everyone
was a member of this particular
community and the same would be true if
someone walked into
a black church and shot it up because
they're mad about what's happening down
the road and yeah
he did it within 10. do you see him i
understand
but it's important look let me just say
this
the first thing they teach you in police
training in the academy the hardest
thing is notifying the victim right
because they want to know why and who
did it even if you have some type of
evidence
you're told not to do it because you
contain an investigation and you just
don't know you can
cause other people to be hurt i guess
politicians
have the luxury of just putting out
misinformation out there it's hurtful
it's bad for the victims it's bad for
the community it's bad for the justice
system
he should know better can i just add to
that then this was the point that i that
i wanted to make it first about the
social media issue there is so much
pressure on people
in positions of power to have answers so
quickly like we all sit here waiting for
a press con
i know i just wanted to add to it and
agree with someone not from the same
party as me
that we're we're screaming well i want
to make sure that i can talk about this
when is someone going to come out and
give us a press conference and then when
they say
we're still following the facts we're
all angry and pissed off about it
because we don't have answers about this
and these things are complicated
and but for a tiny bit of defense of the
mayor and he should have i think raised
this as an issue
that we are seeing a spike in crimes
against lgbtq plus
americans most specifically transgender
americans and if you want to have a
conversation about that i think that
would have been welcome but he should
never have had a butt
that wasn't the platform to do that
because that's that's that
false argument and it said it didn't
happen here
right but it happens over here it's
that's the defense they always use for
fake hate crimes
well okay this one didn't work out but
you know what's happening over there but
then when you
yeah this molet thing was like that may
not be true but it's true somewhere else
you can't do that because it it mutters
the water yeah
right and also senators using the pulse
nightclub shooting
year after year with a false narrative
for their own political game
there's nothing more disgusting than hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else